The collapse of the economy and
social conditions in Venezuela
worries MEPs riots
shortages of food and medicine
crimes and the imprisonment of
opponents of the government are the result
in part of a conflict between the
government of president maduro and the
opposition that  There is a majority in
parliament, what is needed is for the
Maduro regime to currently accept
humanitarian aid so that there is no
risk that the state of exception will
go to a self-coup if the military
is tempted, this could
occur or a civil war in  the time of the
leader of the bolivarian revolution hugo
chávez venezuela was a rich country
thanks to the income from
oil but with the fall in the
prices of this fuel the economy
and the well-being of venezuelans have
sunk there is an economic failure in the
management  from Venezuela that
the government that has governed Venezuela for the last 15
years can be blamed, they believe
Since oil gave money for all that
ended and unfortunately there is no
economy that supports the country's expenses,
the majority of members of the
European Parliament have voted resolutions
in plenary demanding the release of
political prisoners that the government
allows the arrival of the
humanitarian aid and that there is a clear
separation of powers with the
aim of restoring democracy